buongiorno occhio era
il cappello
ma adesso sembra
oggi ho avuto la fortuna di accompagnare
v a fare
tantissima per mcdonald sento di dover
confidare da tutta la nazione un segreto
non so se il mio genere siano pure
redditi perché credo di essermi
perdutamente innamorato di joe
bastianich per me direte voi e grazie a
ragion veduta rosso sono reali sono
ricongiunto lei non volevo innanzitutto
perché se così non arrivò detto di
votare no ti potrei far mangiare
[Musica]
la cosa pazzesca di questi tolleranti e
che ce lo vedete di tutto il leader e
dlp sono operante di oppini disposte ora
io so che son lì 10 in mattina però col
fattore ha annunciato un cambio uno
spuntino di con cipolle no no e lei
ultimo uomo farebbe ma la bellezza la
bellezza
[Musica]
potere iniziare
questo
poi puntare colleghi che vengono mano
io per etica non sto facendo qui quanto
vorrei fare utenti 6 vorrei rimboccarmi
le maniche
guardo dare una mano passera caporali
votarsi ironiche ma mai neppure mi fanno
questa come l'ha saputo cosa pulita ma
non esista più coraggio di imparare a
rivedere giusto tutti ma non bisogna
impugnare panini
[Musica]
avrei dovuto cucinare bene tanto che
collega come gioco abbia avuto il suo
momento di positivo ma cominciamo amico
fratello sono sveglio abbiamo perso
aveva visto ragazzi cucinare sono tipo
sono bellissimi andremo a fare 200 mila
coccia a correre no perché lui non lo
faccio ancora sveglio però una grande
ritorno a casa
e mentre io stavo a guadagnarmi la
pagnotta a tu sei influenzato c'era
qualcuno che ha dormito si è riposato
stacco subito devi dire qualcosa di
scomodo
ok allora ho messo che si è rotta dal
braccio graziano devo assolutamente
assolutamente capire che cosa è successo
ma non adesso che cosa sta succedendo
invece nel frattempo a roma ma un po
paura e chiederlo sinceramente altro
perché posto sesto senso di terrore
quando me ne vado da casa ha deciso è
messo a pierre monopattino da ero carico
la corda che mi sta vedendo che un ma mi
sono fatto una serie di qualsiasi cosa
eccolo strilli di linea mente è questo
qui è un vibratore clitorideo la mia mi
sa che li rende la detto praticamente
che questi qua ha usato o non lo so
penso di sì sì oggi si ritengono al
collo così magari fa fingono in giro che
vedo la tv
voglio faccio vedere anno quando
rimaneva i trilli e siccome sono stato
male è che spesso è un bel libro questo
che non si meritano davvero lo sentono
rumori ma siccome diventa la buona cosa
perché io non ci credo che questo coso
qua hanno regalato non so che cosa sia
allora c'è secondo me cosa pensate in
giro forse sono le cose come si chiamano
ebbe dell ma che dà i numeri non mi
prenderebbe scena è norma questa che ha
scioccato ai ministri presenti strilli
anni ti dico perché chi augura questa
gran parte conforama sono le otto e
mezzo di sera ma basta dormire
lui ha avuto il coraggio di chiedermi
che si mangia lo metti a scaldare un po
di terra simpatico che bello stare
vicino a questa ombra ammalata
io come scusa mi sono messo poi che
l'unico mio colpita fosse a cody archi e
realtà era una scusa per stare a letto
domani devo capire che cosa è successo
ha graziato assolutamente no
io tutte lavorare con la nostra sono
fatte non sapete di chi non si metterà
un pennone il de lostan brella per noi
quella cosa
ragazzi ma andate a fare la spesa voi e
spendere 203 euro che k vede preso per
l'insalata poiché c'è spinacine a 199
nella zona di capra mai capito quante
volte ha fatto carriera nel ballo e se
pure cappello per isaura di cavallo
artigianale 49 euro al chilo ma chi se
li mai bagnata la presa la dica maggio
ha fregato il salmone in tiro e 4 poi si
abbassa già un salmone norvegese non
abbiamo la crema la crema di scampi i
fan di stelle che che li volevano
marchigiana no devo dire del buono
eccezionale con mano quanto è buono però
la ricette a primo la ricetta
siamo venuti a scoprire che cosa è
successo alla nostra grazia nina
graziotto tanti muri ti abbiamo dato in
regalo ora fa mentre l'inter preto e
umile dimora cioè quelle si abbatte il
bomber me le ha regalate a milano anna
cosa stai facendo io ti sto riprendendo
dai treni cucini e amico perché io il
moncone stiamo facendo una frittata ai
broccoli per
per me in realtà ne yo la cosa
importante è
dopo il nostro approfondimento su che
cosa è successo realmente realmente che
cosa è successo realmente al gomito
pochissimo ballando per lavoro a torino
che però io sinceramente vorrei anche un
po vedere oltre che lavorarci porta
perché una città che non conosco per
niente con mio sommo rammarico
[Musica]
non lo so
guarda
[Musica]
lui che vuole comodo vogliamo e non ha
detto no grava su un po di di tentate
sturato una pentola di lenticchie e poi
ha rubato la mia causa e gregor prego
innanzitutto prego si è mangiato da
tutta la pista chiara la realtà sta
mangiando da filippo per diventare pippo
era necessario immangiabili in che senso
nuovo alla quantità di fienili qua
dentro e dire che il viso abbiamo tale
non percepiti e c'è un sacco di scaloni
non diverso nelle spezie più inserito
come che la curry e non si sente c'è no
grazie
ed è bello alla fine io ho cucinato e 30
te chi ha lavato i piatti sempre io fa
deve mai invitare a casa di graziano ma
ha aggiunto roba ma è un pesce ma perché
c'è un pesce graziana ma perché c'è un
pesce che cresce che c'è un pesce nel
lavandino stop per riuscendo a farmi una
battuta per torino che uno è favolosa
fascino super seducente anche un po
malinconico e due tappe can do tutta
gente simpaticissimo e fa parte ha
quindi grazie veramente torinesi per
essere così favolosi ma soprattutto
davanti a me e scorgo pinnacolo di un
enorme moneta da 2 centesimi
quanto so è assolutamente pazzesco
sentirete niente lo state per vedere il
live action di biancaneve bensì è il
momento di fare una chiacchiera con
graziana mentre mi metterà della crema
che è una maschera youth mati made di
glam blog una marca che non conoscevo la
sincerità perché non sei da fare molto
per me parliamo di questo infortunio
come è successo
attraversare la strada mentre guardava a
sinistra che non mi nistero macchine
sono sprofondate in una buca era lì in
questo momento tu sei un po ally mcbeal
contro il comune possiamo dire svolto
talmente a livello entrata altri angeli
tosato di aver bisogno di un ortopedico
e di chi ci aveva messo per me l'ha
aperto da un lato è detto scusami se ho
fatto dieci anni di medicina ad arrivare
a essere un ortopedico tu che tipo di
titolo hai detto io quando questa non è
la dottoressa caldi toros 98 posti ci
fosse venuta una persona anziana magari
si sarebbe spaccato lanka cioè poteva
essere drammatico è per questo che
adesso con alibec b contro il comune di
milano insomma solo per farmi riempire
d'oro per le povere anime pie che
potevano caderci come sei un turista
ora ti devo prendere la grana quindi
redditi non mi trovi pazzesco comunque
questo qui sarà il nostro pasto il
nostro pasto o ma che sta diventato
maurizio costanzo e il noto patto 2
giorno e mi ha costretto e trascinato
come si dice nel vortice di rial auto
tale rotta linee della serie per un
sorriso un segnale o il sorriso abbiamo
fatto dopo pranzo il salto che cos'è un
supermercato orientale il muro ma una
cosa pazzesca immo.c dove stanno
io vorrei provarle tutte quante ci sono
io il qatar ma ciò che mi vuole
siamo a dieta usciamo allora in questo
giro come quanti sono questi che cosa
invece sono cresciuto il filippino
calcolato bianco e dentro
vis colpo al cacao prendiamolo lavoro ma
diventa ma perché ci sei cresciuto dove
si cresce la realtà se cresciuto in cina
era il primo discount nella zona dove
abitavo da ragazzino fammi vedere avere
più di pino
domani è la mia prima ancora di sono un
po comunque sociale secondo aqua
continuiamo imperterriti a guardare le
nostre realize fatto il tipo e la banana
per il 2020 io e lui abbiamo deciso di
fare una cosa vista e stiamo finendo
come le magliette sul sito di programma
molte persone e fare un regalo di
augurio per il nuovo anno abbiamo preso
un t ben accetti del willy o non so se
vi ricordate sono quelli di che
quest'estate ho dato tutte le persone
che ho incontrato per il milione di
iscritti
li stiamo infondendo con della fortuna
in modo da spedirli insieme a le
magliette per gli ultimi acquisti e
questa cosa si sta facendo e leader
perché stavo passo della specie di rito
per infondere fortuna fortuna ma la
fortuna anche a te siete più fortunati
nero rosa e verde ognuno di voi sanno
fortunatissimo fortunatissima american
beauty ma più che altro iniziato i
calamari ma fa niente fortunatissimo
sabrina partire da oggi ho un ospite
particolare pronti a tutto che per forza
stare in mezzo colleghi no no no questo
qui è parte della roba che se siamo
bagnati gli avanzano molto di più di
questo stanze stato di ok non quello che
dico io è che se conosce
da martedì strambi
quello no quello no assumere solo regge
ma quello che non c'è ma è vero ma la
verità
ga ga ga hoole alla roma un'ora di
chiacchierata nella quale le prime
gianluigi hanno litigato come dei
dannati qualcosa mi dice che devo
tornare a roma che incontrerò il delirio
cosmico ma ragazzo un'ora su google plus
con consensi scopriamo che sta
succedendo
buongiorno sono arrivato a roma è dovuta
alle linee a prendermi che dobbiamo
parlare allora stiamo andando a
incontrare dio santo che pure de roma
sarà tra una riunione con gianmarco ed
enrico sia di lavoro che per parlare ed
è scappato da bollente una cosa il
delirio ma io non ce la faccio più
concreta è che cosa hanno fatto e stanno
tara mi hanno chiamato hanno iniziato a
litigare ma rulli di tamburi
il prossimo episodio che egli non è
giusto ma io sono vecchio veramente mi
farà male questo vai a fare